good I'm Patricia Francis from the
International Trade Center and the
session I was in his unlocking Africa's
growth potential we looked at the issues
that would create opportunities for
doing this particularly in the business
environment and we thought the first
thing that should happen is that there
should be a partnership between public
and private sector as well as civil
society to agree on the way forward and
to build consensus trust and confidence
as well as a common vision as to where
the countries should go this would be a
way of building consensus and this would
be a way of reducing the risk of failure
in terms of risk mitigation how to how
to move investment forward we also
thought that it was important to have
clear rules and regulations and
independent judicial system reforms of
banking system access to infrastructure
and information political commitment and
these were very important because there
was a feeling that there was great
opacity no transparency in how things
are done and this is the only way that
you can really build a forward movement
then to actually make things happen
there needed to be priorities how could
you set priorities on what should be
done there are so many things to be done
you need to set priorities and around
those priorities we looked at best
practices how some of this had been done
seeing India in China in an enclave that
may be a way to start that could be a
possibly good way but we also saw a good
practices in Rwanda and in Ghana one
with a one stop shop which integrates
all of the approval process and one
which accommodates and accompanies you
through the the investment process and
finally regional integration was was a
very great importance especially
landlocked countries which needed to
have a regional approach to their own
development and for their investment
policies and of course for investment
one needed to have image building and
one should never forget a policy towards
making sure that your local investors
were also included